- So not surprisingly,
everyone wants to know if
Roe versus Wade is dead.
And if the prior decision
of the Supreme Court
is any indication, the
answer is probably yes.
As you may know,
under the current Supreme
Court jurisprudence,
under Casey versus Planned Parenthood,
abortion rights are basically governed
by a viability standard.
Basically, abortions are legal
if it is done before
viability of the fetus.
That is a change from the
original Roe vs. Wade standard
that dealt with the trimester framework.
But when the Supreme
Court let the Texas law
that basically said no
abortions before six weeks,
and maybe not even then,
it basically signaled
that Roe vs. Wade and its progeny is over,
including Casey versus Planned Parenthood.
This was on the court's shadow docket,
so it carries no precedential effect.
But if there was a majority of
justices on the Supreme Court
who still believed in a
constitutional right to abortion,
they would have stayed the proceedings
and not let the Texas law go into effect.
But they didn't, which signals
that when this comes up
on the merits docket,
they will basically overturn Roe vs. Wade.
But this is definitely
going to come up next term,
so we'll see them in court.